dann liegt das was macht die afg gerade
für junge männer so interessant das
wollen wir heute besprechen mit dem
politikwissenschaftler benjamin höhner
er beschäftigt sich schon lange mit dem
phänomen aber bevor wir das tun gucken
das noch mal an wie eigentlich die unter
30-jährigen in thüringen gestern gewählt
haben bei der landtagswahl in thüringen
haben wähler die jünger als 30 jahre alt
sind diesen parteien ihre stimme gegeben
23 prozent wählten die linke aber die
meisten stimmen bekam die afd
mit insgesamt 25 prozent das afd wähler
eher jung aber auch männlich sind zeigt
auch dieses ergebnis 18 prozent der
frauen in diesem alter welten die afd
bei männern der gleichen altersgruppe
waren es 30 prozent
also ganz klar entweder linke oder afd
wurden bei gewählt 39 jährigen das war
bei der letzten wahl noch nicht so
deutlich und woran das liegt das möchte
ich erst besprechen mit dem
politikwissenschaftler benjamin hübner
der ist mir in berlin zugeschaltet hallo
mal schlimmer noch die haben es gesehen
junge wählen entweder linke oder afd was
es mit den armen passiert mit cdu und
spd
der generelle trend dem in thürigen
beobachten konnten ist ja der dass es
eine art polarisierung zwischen der afd
auf der rechten seite und der
linkspartei auf der linken seite gab
und da sind die bürgerlichen sogenannten
bürgerlichen parteien und die parteien
links der mitte also sozialdemokraten
und bündnis 90/die grüne ein stück weit
unter die räder gekommen es hängt auch
damit zusammen dass es einen
konzentrations effekt auch die
ministerpräsidenten partei gab das haben
wir schon in sachsen beobachten können
und auch in brandenburg sachsen hat die
cdu davon profitiert in brandenburg die
spd und in thüringen war es eben die
linkspartei die davon profitiert hat von
diesen konzentrations effekt und das
heißt eigentlich dass der ein oder
andere der bisher vielleicht nie die
linkspartei gewählt hat nun aus
strategischen gründen sein kreuz bei der
linkspartei gemacht hat einfach um zu
verhindern dass die afg stärkste partei
wird heißt das im umkehrschluss auch
dass die menschen in thüringen vor allem
dann wenn heckel gewählt haben wenn sie
ihre köpfe geht das ist das interessante
und auch in gewisser weise
besorgniserregende an dem wahlergebnis
weil es gab er die debatte um den
terrorakt
von halle und welche rolle die afg dabei
gespielt hat dass es zu einer verrohung
der sprache der politischen kultur der
auseinandersetzung kommt dass da also
irgendwie so ein vorfeld geschaffen wird
wo sich menschen radikalisieren und dann
war auch allen wählern bekannte dass wir
sozusagen die spitzen figur der afc in
thüringen ist und trotz dieser debatte
und des spitzenvertreter der weit am
rechten rand der afg zu verorten ist hat
man die fdp wählt insofern greift es nur
noch bedingt oder greift nur noch zum
teil dass man sagte na ja da wollte man
protest artikulieren oder da ist der ein
oder andere weder dabei der verdruss zum
ausdruck bringen wollte das klappt nicht
mehr in gänze weil man eben wusste
worauf man sich einlässt darauf gucken
dass es eigentlich immer so zumindest
vom klischee her war das die afg einer
eher partei der alten gewesen ist also
eher der 60 jährigen dann ist doch jetzt
die frage da was bietet denn die partei
gerade jungen menschen oder jüngeren
menschen im osten an dass sie sagen ja
da mache ich mein kreuz
gute frage ich glaube dass generell sich
junge menschen mit der etablierten
parteipolitik schwer tun das wissen wir
wenn wir den parteien zugegen sind dort
befragung machen gerade die partei mit
volksparteien anspruch haben der massive
probleme junger menschen zur mitarbeit
zu begeistern auch für ihre programmatik
oder spitzenpersonal zu begeistern also
da fremdelte man doch ziemlich stark
sie war aber dass das kleineren parteien
wie den grünen der fdp ganz gut gelingt
dann den zugang zu jungen menschen zu
schaffen und bei der ft ist das in der
ein interessantes phänomen also warum da
auch der zuspruch durch junge menschen
erfolgt ist weil man konstatieren muss
dass die ard jack einen zielgerichteten
auf junge menschen ausgerichteten
wahlkampf geführt hat weder in thüringen
noch in den anderen bundesländern
aber man kann auf der anderen seite auch
sagen dass sie sich sehr internet social
media affin gibt und von daher den ein
oder anderen vielleicht dort abgeholt
hat in der online welt wo er sich
befindet wo andere parteien insbesondere
die größeren parteien nach wie vor
schwierigkeiten
die idee neben der afg ich meine wenn
man sie mal ein ganz herunterbricht ist
es ja vor allem
das nationale rückbesinnung auf den
nationalstaat du ist die afg entstanden
das ist ja eigentlich eine uralte idee
wieso kommt die jetzt wieder hoch und
pop quasi auf und junge leute sagen
super dann den schließe ich mich an da
vermischt sich einiges bei der afg also
klar der nationalismus ist keine neue
erfindung aber was das neue am
populismus ist dass das man oder dass
populisten einen vermeintlichen
konflikte zwischen dem guten ehrbaren
volk auf der einen seite und der
korrupten politischen elite auf der
anderen seite konstruieren das hat auch
was ideologisches und sich dann auf dem
wählermarkt positionieren und sagen und
wir jetzt als populistische partei in
deutschland eben die fdp wir versuchen
wieder das gute ehrwürdige volk mit der
politik zusammen zu bringen indem ihr
uns als partei wählt und offenbar ist
das eben auch eine rhetorik die bei
jungen menschen verhängt was man bisher
gar nicht so auf dem schirm hatte weil
man in der tat dachte das ist eher etwas
für die ältere generation also dass sehr
viel beschworene bild der älteren weißen
männer die da eine gewisse anfälligkeit
gegenüber den populismus aufzeigen und
jetzt sehen wir zumindest bei der wahl
in thüringen dass die alterskohorte ab
60 gar nicht mal die stärkste ist wohl
der stärkste zuspruch gegen würde er auf
die erfolgt ist aber wir haben ja auf
der einen seite seine jugend wirkung wie
schneiders for future wo sich junge
menschen dahinter stellen und für was
ganz anderes einstehen für eine
weltoffene gemeinsame globale kultur wo
alle zusammenarbeiten müssen um quasi
den klimawandel zu stoppen während die
afg komplett auf der anderen seite steht
und sagt erstens jeder für sich alleine
und zweitens klimawandel gibt es gar
nicht wir haben andere probleme
was sind das für menschen oder was ist
denn das für ein weltbild dahinter dann
dem sich oder was für menschen können
sich dem anschließen das scheint ja doch
andere menschen zu sein als die die zwei
jobs for future gehen ja guter punkt und
ich glaube durch dadurch dass freiheit
future in den medien ziemlich sich
lautstark gehör verschafft konnte da der
eine oder andere den eindruck gewinnen
dass frei das for future als
jugendbewegung für die jugend per se
spricht oder für die jugend
ihrer gesamtheit und das sehen wir wenn
wir uns die jüngsten wahlergebnisse eben
auch in thüringen anschauen dass das
nicht der fall ist dass dadurch ein
beträchtlicher anteil auch an jungen
menschen eben nicht die anliegen und
sorgen von freitag 5 user teilt in bezug
auf klimawandel umwelt und so weiter und
so fort bei dem populismus phänomen
sollte man glaube ich tatsächlich er
festhalten dass es eine
altersübergreifende phänomen ist dass
auch in den schicht übergreifendes
phänomen ist das also vielfältige teile
in der bevölkerung anspricht und muss
man auch dazusagen dass populisten in
ihrer rhetorik ziemlich geschickt sind
das heißt also wahlweise auch die themen
integrieren können aufnehmen können und
mit diesen versuchen bei wahlen zu
realisieren von denen sie sich maximalen
erfolg versprechen
jetzt gucken wir mal den kommentare ich
versuche mal einen kommentar zu finden
oder eine frage zu finden
die derzeitige mit rein nehmen können
auf youtube geht es ganz schön ab aber
so richtig sie gerichtet scheint mir
dass gerade noch nicht zu sein dass zum
beispiel das könnte ich mal mit
einnehmen konrad adenauer fragt welche
forderungen der afg ist rechtsradikal
die einhaltung von gesetzen vielleicht
dass man als einordnung von ihnen welche
forderungen der afg würden sie als
rechtsradikal einstufen oder gibt es
überhaupt keine forderung wo sie sagen
dieses rechtsradikal
naja ich habe da muss man unterscheiden
zwischen den programmen zwischen dem
grundsatzprogramm den wahlprogrammen wo
auch die afg versuchte eine wähler
maximierung strategie zu verfolgen das
heißt da wird man sich jetzt an wird man
nicht ins rechtsextreme oder als
rechtsradikale abdriften aber wenn wir
die eine oder andere äußerung von
spitzen figuren nehmen eben wie von
herrn röcke in thüringen dann kann man
schon gewisse grenzüberschreitung in
diese richtung nachvollziehen
und man muss auch sagen dass das ja auch
eine frage ist die bei der afg selbst
umstritten ist also inwieweit geht man
nach rechts oder inwieweit positioniert
man sich rechts der cdu er in der
sogenannten bürgerlichen mitte und da
gibt es ja eigentlich 22 lager wenn man
so möchte die einen dieser
wir dürfen nicht zu weit als afd nach
rechts gehen in das rechtsextreme weil
das in deutschland ziemlich gefährlich
ist aufgrund der nationalsozialistischen
vergangenheit und da sehen wir jetzt am
beispiel von thüringen das ist offenbar
der partei nicht geschadet hat dass sie
mit einer spitze figur eingetreten ist
die damit an der einen oder anderen
stelle kokettiert ist das quasi den
wählern egal gewesen kann man das jetzt
schon feststellen oder gibt es da noch
keine erhebungen zu ja das müssen wir
jetzt spekulieren aber offenbar es ist
tatsächlich so dass es jetzt keine
negativen effekte hatte es gibt auch die
anderen stimmen die sagen auch innerhalb
der afc wenn eine andere spitzen figur
dort gewesen wäre dann hätte man noch
mehr für die after ausholen können das
halte ich aber für nicht sehr plausibel
insofern glaube ich ist es tatsächlich
vielen wählern egal gewesen und dann
muss man sich auch schon fragen oder
muss ihnen auch bewusst machen was sie
da gewählt haben und dass sie auch
verantwortung letztlich tragen wir haben
heute mal versucht mit menschen zu
sprechen auf der straße in thüringen die
afg gewählt haben das war gar nicht mal
so einfach die meisten wollten nämlich
nicht mit uns reden ein paar haben es
trotzdem getan und das ist dabei
rausgekommen
auf der 24 prozent erreicht so schön
heutzutage kann man keine parteien
wählen weil alle machen nur ein
wahlversprechen hält sich dran
der kleine mann ich zähle mich einfach
mal dazu wir haben nicht wirklich
druckmittel aber man kann ein bisschen
da druck machen indem man halt das wählt
was ein bisschen quer schießt die
geschichte die befragten sich herum
machen dass wir die heute wiederum für
die verschönerung des leute sowas wählen
können wo man weiß wohin gilt ja also es
war relativ deutlich die beiden jungen
männer die wir gefunden haben waren pro
afd und der alte ältere herr der war
dagegen aber die beiden langen doch
ziemlich nach protest fehlern also nach
dem wunsch gehört zu werden mit seinem
anliegen was sind denn das für anlegen
wo die menschen sagen wir werden von den
etablierten in anführungszeichen
parteien wobei die afg ist mittlerweile
etabliert eigentlich nicht mehr
wahrgenommen
ja so das ist interessant insbesondere
das zitat von dem zweiten herren weil
das ja so eine typische figur ist die
immer wieder transportiert wird der
kleine mann der von der etablierten
politik vernachlässigt wird
der umbau abgehängt ist um den man sich
nicht mehr ausreichend kümmert der marke
individuell an der einen stelle
tatsächlich etwas dran sein dass man
sich die situation anschauen kann
das ist aber für meinen geschmack auch
immer ziemlich diffus diese figur so
heraus zu stellen weil im prinzip ja
jeder in deutschland die möglichkeiten
hat sich zu artikulieren sich
einzubringen und seine stimme auch etwas
zählt also ich glaube da vermischt sich
so ein bisschen das angebot das
populistische parteien unterbreiten und
die rhetorik mit der sie an den start
gehen eben dieses ideologische moment
einen konflikt zwischen dem dem den den
guten volk und den korrupten eliten auf
der einen seite zu schaffen und dann
wiederum der nachfrage
die dabei auch ein stückweit generiert
wird durch populistische parteien oder
zumindest in bestimmten
bevölkerungskreisen verfängt und das
wären wir wahrscheinlich uns auch noch
anschauen das ist ja auch einen
zusammenhang zwischen dem bildungsniveau
und der einfältigkeit dafür gibt den
populistischen versprechen glauben zu
schenken das hat das wollte ich gerade
fragen was ist denn jetzt quasi so ein
ein merkmal von menschen die populisten
ihre stimme geben kann man das jetzt
schon in etwas sagen sind es menschen
die eher angst haben vor veränderungen
die eher liberal sind also eher nicht
für eine weltoffene gesellschaft weil
sie die befürchtung haben die kontrolle
zu verlieren oder sind das noch mal ganz
andere motive das ist eine schwierige
frage wo die wahlforschung auch durchaus
unterschiedliche antworten gibt je
nachdem in welchem land man sich
befindet über welche gruppen man spricht
also es gibt verschiedene ansätze man
kann das vielleicht mal kurz
unterbrechen und sagen es gibt nur so
zur ökonomischen einsatz also da geht es
dann um ökonomische benachteiligung oder
auch nur das gefühl einer
benachteiligung oder noch eine stufe
weiter einer potenziellen ökonomische
benachteiligung die dazu führt dass
menschen populistisch wählen also
menschen haben angst davor dass ist dass
ihnen was fehlt irgendwann oder sie
haben schon erfahrung gemacht dass ihnen
was fehlt oder es fehlt eben ganz
konkret was genau sind also ist es nicht
nur der eine ansatz und da sicherlich
auch über sozialisation insbesondere im
osten da wird durch die ältere
generation auf die jüngere
generation das ein oder andere
übertragen und da kann man ja schon
konstatieren dass transformations-
erfahrung die im osten alle menschen
durchmachen mussten nicht unbedingt bei
jedem auch als positive erfahrung
gesehen werden und wenn so was sozial
dieser torische über die älteren
generationen an jüngere weiter gegeben
wird kann das schon auch bei dem einen
oder anderen dann ein wichtiger
beweggrund seien aber die die der
sozioökonomische erklärungsansatz der
greift nicht allein sondern hat dann
noch den soziokulturellen und der hängt
der stark mit modernisierung zusammen
mit veränderung und da spielen dann
unterschiedlich sehr faktoren eine rolle
also überfremdungsängste angst vor
migration angst vor kultureller
veränderung also das ist ein ganz
breites sammelsurium an erklärungs
faktoren und dann der dritte punkt der
wäre mir auch noch wichtig auch über
diesen zu sprechen
ich glaube manchmal wobei man das mit
forschung noch viel stärker unter setzen
müsste dass es auch so moment wie in
einem allgemein diffusen verdruss an den
mechanismen der etablierten demokratie
und ihren verfahren gibt die gewisse
gewöhnung über gewöhnung und da auch
eine gewisse bereitwilligkeit das was
man hat nicht mehr so richtig schätzt
auch durch etwas zu auszutauschen was
erstmal vielleicht bei dem einen oder
anderen ganz gut klingt letztlich aber
keine keine keine substanzielle
situations verbesserung mit sich bringt
wir gucken noch mal hier in die
kommentare ich bin da mal auf twitter
über gehüpft da schreibt herr may man
auf unsere auf unseren tweets oder auf
unseren live stream ich glaube die vom
westen dominierte politik nimmt die
bedürfnisse und sorgen im osten nicht
für ernst
anstatt nach bedürfnissen und sorgen zu
fragen grübelt man darüber warum der
osten falsch wählt das recht sich gerade
würden sie das unterschreiben
das ist die ost west debatte die könnte
man jetzt auch aufgreifen ist auch
wichtig darüber zu sprechen aber man
kann an dieser stelle zunächst auch
sagen dass sie versucht worden ist
gerade auch in den wahlkämpfen in
brandenburg und sachsen durch die 8d zu
instrumentalisieren
also dass man da genau mit diesem gefühl
der benachteiligung versucht hatte sich
als der partei aufzuspielen die
irgendwie sich in die tradition der der
reformbewegung in der untergehenden ddr
stellt aber wie gesagt das ist eine
instrumentalisierung ansonsten die ost
west debatte da liegt sicherlich nicht
alles richtig in den vergangenen 10 20
30 jahren da kann man recht geben aber
umso wichtiger ist es doch dass die
ostdeutschen sich jetzt auf andere art
und weise versuchen gehör zu verschaffen
aber man kann sich ja indem sie offen
über ihre über ihre befindlichkeiten
reden und dann auch der in
anführungsstrichen wessi weiß was die
befindlichkeiten die bedürfnisse sind
und dass man da auch einen dialog auf
augenhöhe führen kann wenn man das zu
spitz kann man noch sagen bisher war das
zumindest bei der älteren generation in
teilen so dass sehen sie bitte auch als
these dass vom westen der solidaritäts
zuschlag gezahlt worden ist also
richtige aufbauhilfe ost gezahlt worden
ist und bitte doch der der ostdeutsche
da nicht meckern sollte wenn an der
einen stelle etwas nicht so lief und das
hat er in der tat vielleicht auch nicht
so gemacht wie es hätte machen soll
also wir fassen mal zusammen wir haben
einen ost-west-konflikt oder zumindest
ein ost-west-gefälle wir haben im osten
wende erfahrungen die natürlich auch
nicht bei allen positiv waren
was hatten sie noch gesagt es gibt
natürlich ängste davor dass man etwas
verliert was man schon hat oder man hat
tatsächlich schon ökonomisch probleme
und das sieht man noch mehr werden
wandel in der welt kommen und deswegen
hat man möchte man eher zurück in das in
das gute alte das nationale
dann gibt es persönliche beweggründe das
einfach menschen angst haben vor
veränderungen das ist ja schon strauß
von von sehr sehr vielen antworten jetzt
kommt ja auch noch die frage sie haben
es auch kurz angesprochen liegt es an
der mangelhaften bildung und dummheit in
der familie auf twitter von anthony
pilavachi also bildung kann das auch
noch was damit zu tun haben dass
menschen die eine höhere bildung haben
er anders wären dass menschen mit
weniger bildung ja ich hab das zeigt die
wahlforschung ziemlich eindeutig dass
mit zunehmenden bildungsniveau die
anfälligkeit sind populistisch zu wählen
das hat mit dem gewissen mit dem
verdruss argument ein stück weit zu tun
weil ich meine unsere demokratie in der
wir heute leben die ist super komplex
wie beschreiben sie der
politikwissenschaft als mehr ebenen
demokratie das heißt es gibt die
landesebene es gibt die bundesebene es
gibt in europa ebene und diese ebene
sind vielfältig miteinander verwoben
sind an allen möglichen stellen
kompromisse notwendig dann wird das
ganze überlagert durch partei durch
parteien durch parteipolitische akteure
also demokratie bedeutet heute mehr denn
je kompromiss und diese kompromisse zu
verstehen und auch sie zu würdigen das
fällt wahrscheinlich schon leichter wenn
man ein ein höheres bildungsniveau
mitbringen würde ich behaupten so ich
gehe noch mal auf youtube in die
versuchen normalen sinnvollen kommentare
zu finden könnte wissen schwierig werden
der borusse wirft ihnen vor dass sie
keine frage total normal beantworten
sie würden einfach nur rum labern okay
dass das noch mal so stehen dann nichts
es kann also doch ich habe große ja ich
krieg geradeaus von einem redakteur
gesagt nicht so stehen darf natürlich
nicht so stehen lassen aber was soll ich
dazu sagen
das ist natürlich einfach ein relativ um
konstruktive kommentar der nicht richtig
viel zur debatte beiträgt software
trikot wird uns vor wir hätten die die
ostdeutschen hätten schon seit jahren
über die probleme geredet das wäre
heuchelei in jetzt quasi vorzuwerfen sie
würden ihren mund nicht aufmachen ist es
ist es so kann man nicht sagen
die ostdeutschen sagen doch schon seit
jahren was ihnen alles nicht passt und
dass bei ihnen das nicht so ist wie sich
das vorgestellt haben nach der wende ja
gute frage na klar wurde schon immer
kommuniziert aber ich hab
so ein wenig das gefühl dass sie die
jüngere generation ihre interessen
selbstbewusster kommuniziert und auch in
ganz anderen dialog hineingehen kann und
wenn man sich die generation angeschaut
hat nach 1990 also unsere eltern
generation vielleicht oder auch die die
großeltern generation
dann waren ja gar nicht so an
demokratische prozesse gewöhnt also sich
zu artikulieren sich verständlich zu
machen und auch in eine debatte hinein
zu gehen
ich glaube da wirkte er aus der ddr
vergangenheit vieles erst mal noch ein
stück weiter nach wo es eben kein
offenen umgang oder keine offenen
debatten gab sondern wenn man sich
unterhalten hat dann war das im kleinen
kreis der geschützten familie und immer
war natürlich die befürchtung da das
doch irgendwo jemand von der stasi mit
an bord es sind ja das alles schön
aufschreibt und am nächsten morgen eine
meldung macht also insofern gab es da
keine debatten kultur wie sie in
westdeutschland über jahrzehnte hin
gereift ist so dass am anfang glaube ich
eben keine debatte so richtig auf
augenhöhe stattfinden konnte das ist das
und dann würde ich gern noch einen
weiteren punkt nennen der wichtig ist
zur erklärung wenn ich das an der stelle
darf bitte ja nämlich das hat damit zu
tun mit dem parteiensystem
das richtet sich vielleicht jetzt auch
an die einen kommentar von eben also im
ganz einfach ausgedrückt im westen hat
sich das parteiensystem das etablierte
parteiensystem über jahrzehnte
herausgebildet das gibt es also ganz
viele stammwähler die über jahrzehnte
hinweg die gleiche partei im prinzip
wählen natürlich die figur des stamm b
das wird auch im westen etwas schwächer
aber im osten ist sie nie so aufgetreten
war das parteiensystem mehr oder minder
vom westen in den osten verpflanzt wurde
und dort sich nie so richtig so stark
verwurzelt hat und diese fehlende starke
verwurzelung des etablierten parteien
systems die ist natürlich dann für neue
akteure
ob das jetzt eine neue soziale bewegung
ist die politischen parteien politischen
anspruch hat oder ob das eine
rechtspopulistische partei pd f d ist
ist es für die dann natürlich einfacher
diese in diese lücke hinein zu stoßen
wenn man so möchte ich mache jetzt
nochmal 2 kommentare hier auch auf
youtube schmusen schreibt warum versteht
man nicht dass die afg als einzige gegen
überfremdung und identitätsverlust ist
das merkt man als jugendlicher erst
recht im internet und misst das liefert
er unterschreibt ich bin selber nicht
hier geboren aber ich bin nicht in ein
islamisches ghetto ausgewandert wieso
verwandelt man deutschland jetzt in 1
das heißt die themen die die afg hier
besetzt sind relativ eindeutig hier
migration und angst vor islamisierung
warum sind diese themen so richtig dass
menschen entschließen nur aufgrund
dieses ein thema seiner partei zu wählen
die sonst eigentlich wir nicht
inhaltlich so richtig viel zu bieten hat
bis jetzt gute frage also ich glaube in
beiden kommentaren hat sich ja doch ein
hohes potenzial auch an angst
widergespiegelt interessanterweise ist
es ja so was die tatsächliche was das
tatsächliche gründe für angst anbelangt
dass sie im osten wesentliche rarer
gesät sind also wenn man sich den anteil
von migranten dem osten anschaut ist er
ja in vielen stellen wesentlich geringer
als im westen gefeiert
der fall ist und ich glaube das hat ein
stück weit auch eben damit zu tun ob man
es gewöhnt ist auf kulturelle
andersartigkeit in seinem umfeld zu
treffen oder ob das eher eine ausnahme
ist oder gar nicht stattfindet also
gehen wir mal in größere städte hinein
wo es ganz normal dass wenn man abends
ins restaurant geht dass man kulturell
andersartige menschen sieht dann findet
man dabei nichts mehr so speziell
besonderes wenn man jetzt aber in einer
gegend lebt wo das selten oder nie der
fall ist das man da mal jemand sieht der
kulturell anders in erscheinung tritt
dann kann das schon an der einen stelle
zumindest berührungsängste erstmal
bedeutet man muss dann sozusagen in
großstädten gibt es auch rechtsradikale
dortmund erst mal ganz gut dann hochburg
davon ja richtig aber insofern ein
plädoyer für für austausch kulturellen
austausch insbesondere unter
jugendlichen geben das ist super wichtig
aber man sieht schon wenn man da
zwischen urbanen zentren und ländlichen
regionen unterscheidet auch das können
wir uns für thüringen anschauen dass die
kfd in
ländlichen region tendenziell stärker
ist als das in urbanen zentren ist und
den urbanen zentren insbesondere wenn
dann noch universitäre milieus hinzu
kommt die grünen natürlich traditionell
stark also da hat man tatsächlich auch
ein zentrum oder einen stadt land
konflikt wenn man so möchte so jetzt
möchte noch mal auf 2 kommentare
eingehen bevor wir den sack zumachen
einmal schreibt emmi hier gemerkt
gleicht der eingriff vom redakteur an
den armen oder radtour als er vorlas
herrlich lieber rwk charaktere kann ihn
nicht eingreifen ich könnte jetzt was
erzählt und er hat überhaupt keine also
wirklich könnte nichts machen das tut
mir leid
jetzt reden wir nicht wo ich versuche
hier dem epi zu erklären dass du nichts
machen kannst und eine sache die uns
öfter jetzt vorgeworfen wurde an sie
herr höhne
sie seien aus dem westen und sollten
doch bitte ich sag's mal freundlich den
mund halten können sie kurz mal sagen wo
sie herkommen sie haben offenbar gut
recherchiert also ich bin gebürtiger
ostdeutscher in lutherstadt wittenberg
geworden habe meinen universitäts
abschluss an der schönen
martin-luther-universität
halle-wittenberg gemacht behauptet
tatsächlich mal eine zeit lang im westen
in rheinland pfalz im schönen trier und
bin dann aber seit einiger zeit wieder
zurückgekehrte eine halle und jetzt zur
zeit in berlin an einem
forschungsinstitut tätig und damit man
mich nicht fascher steht also ich sehe
viele punkte und sehe auch das mit einer
gewissen
wie soll man sagen oder das ist an der
ein oder anderen stelle bei
westdeutschen gefehlt hat sich
tiefergehend auf ostdeutsche
befindlichkeiten einzulassen oder dass
sie das ostdeutsche gemessen worden sind
mit den eigenen ansprüchen
erwartungshaltungen und so weiter und so
fort und aus deutsche aber dazu wenig
auch gern gehalten haben und das war
mein punkt jetzt macht man das stärker
und dann kann man sich eben auch auf
eine debatte auf augenhöhe einlassen
dann hoffen wir dass die stattfindet und
hoffentlich auch ziviler als das
teilweise im netz der fall ist und damit
bedanke ich mich für alle die
konstruktiv mit diskutiert haben ich
bedanke mich bei ihnen herr höhne für
die zeit heute abend und sagt bis zum
nächsten stream erstmal vielen dank und
tschüss
[Musik]
und mehr zum thema gibt es hier oben da
haben wir mit der afg aussteigerin
franziska schreiber gesprochen oder hier
geht es zum thema feindbild suv und
natürlich lasst uns likes kommentare und
viel liebe da vielen dank